We are now ready to answer the question,
are there fragile regions in
the human genome?
Here is a theorem, yes!
And here is the proof.
If the Random Breakage Model is correct,
then N rearrangements applied to circular
chromosomes will produce
approximately 2N synteny blocks.
And therefore since there are 280
human-mouse synteny blocks, there must
have been approximately 280 over 2
which is 140 2-breaks on the human mouse
evolutionary path.
But we have just learned from the 2-Break
Distance Theorem
that there are at least 245
2-breaks on this path.
My next question
is 245 equal to 140?
It turns out that 245 is much larger than
140, even
if you apply rigorous statistic allowing
for some differences between these
numbers, which means that we arrive at the
contradiction, implying
that one of our assumptions, in the course
of proving this theorem, is
incorrect.
But which one?
Well, there is not much choice, because we
have made only one assumption.
Here it is.
If the Random Breakage Model is correct,
and since we based on this assumption
we arrived to a contradiction, it means
that our assumption was incorrect.
Which implies that Random Breakage Model
failed.
Well, we demonstrated
that Random Breakage Model is incorrect
but of course we have not provided
you with the location of fragile regions
in the human genome and it
is an example of a non constructive proof
when we prove that something is wrong
but cannot provide a certificate showing
where the fragile regions are located.
But if the random breakage model isn't
correct, how would you explain the
remarkable
fit between the short length of synteny
blocks and the exponential distribution?
Well, why have biologists embraced random
breakage model?
Actually it was a logical fallacy.
RBM, Random Breakage Model, is not the
only model that complies with the
exponential distribution test, so it is
correct to claim the Random Breakage Model
implies exponential distribution.
But it is absolutely incorrect to
claim that exponential distribution
implies the Random Breakage Model.
So why was Random Breakage Model refuted?
Because it doesn't comply with the
observed breakpoint reuse.
And the question is, is there a model that
complies with both the
exponential distribution and the
breakpoint reuse phenomena?
And it turned out that so called
Fragile Breakage Model indeed explained
both phenomena.
According to the fragile breakage model,
our genomes represent a mosaic or fragile
regions
with this high propensity for arrangements
and solid region that hardly ever broken
by their arrangements.
And fragile regions which means regions
between
consecutive synteny blocks are short,
accounting, let's
say in the case of human genome for less
than 5% of our genes.
Now, the question of course arises, how
FBM, Far Fragile Breakage Model,
explained both exponential distribution
and the rearrangement hotspots.
Well, a small number of short fragile
regions explain rearrangement hotspots
because there are very few regions where
rearrangements actually can happen.
Therefore, they are bound to be repeated
in the same places.
Also, if fragile regions are somewhat
randomly distributed throughout
the genome, then the synteny blocks lands
follow exactly
the same exponential distribution, as in
the case of the Random Breakage Model.
And therefore, the Fragile Breakage Model
explained both exponential distribution
and breakpoint reuse.
And should be used as a substitute for the
random breakage model.
But, maybe fragile breakage model uses the
same logical fallacy that the random
breakage model
uses, because maybe, there is a test that
was random breakage model and fragile
breakage model fail.
It turn out very recently that indeed
there is such a test.
And this test became possible because many
genomes have been
sequenced in recent years, and scientists
were able to analyze breakpoints not
only between two genomes, human and mouse,
the first sequenced genome, but between
multiple genomes.
And they proposed so-called Multiply
Breakpoint Reuse test
which analyzes breakpoints across
multiply genomes.
Unfortunately, we don't have time to go in
the details of the
Multiply Break Point reuse test, but I can
only tell you what follows
from a study that analyzes that.
This recent study revealed evidence for
births and deaths of the fragile
regions, which means that, fragile
regions exist but they're not static.
They move to different locations in human
and mouse genome and the positions of the
fragile regions in the human genome
are different
than the positions of the fragile regions
in mouse genome.
And this discovery resulted in the
Turnover Fragile Breakage Model
which allows for changes, in the location
of fragile regions.
And this new
Turnover Fragile Breakage Model
actually complies with a new Multiply
Breakpoint Reuse Test.
Moreover, it actually points to the
location of the currently fragile regions.
They're questions that we were not able to
answer when
we were proving the last theorem from the
last section.
So Turnover Fragile Breakage Model
actually complies with all three tests.
Does it mean that's it's absolutely final
model for chromosome evolution?
Of course not, there's always
possibilities that
future studies will reveal new and new
tests.
And will lead to further development of
the of our views of chromosome evolution.
And with Turnover Fragile Breakage Model
developed,
there are still questions that remain to be
answered.
Where are the fragile regions located?
And what causes fragility?
And availability of multiplied genomes
will help us eventually to answer this
question and to figure out
what are the currently active fragile
regions in the human genome?
What will be maybe the next reversal that
happened in the human genome.
Let's say the next million years.
And now, after we cover a
different algorithmic aspect of genome
rearrangement, the time has come to
answer one of the first questions that
appeared in this lesson.
How to generate synteny blocks
starting from long genomes?